[Music]
please pardon the interruption attention
a student that please initiate internal
lockdown procedure at this time I repeat
please initiate internal lockdown
procedure effective time hello and
welcome to all taint a creepypasta
horror stories cooked to perfection with
a splash of red sauce my name is cz and
I will be your server of this episode
brake is now over which means it's time
to get back to creepy clown school
lockdown let's dig right in
I had been waiting all year for the
floor hockey unit in gym this year I was
out for blood there's this kid at my
school Callum who thinks he's just the
greatest thing that ever happened to any
of us he plays on a traveling ice hockey
team so every year when we get to the
hockey unit he single-handedly
outclasses everyone but that's not
enough for Callum oh no he has to show
off use all his fancy little tricks his
team wins every single game and he makes
it look easy like he's not even
interested in trying as if his cocky
attitude wasn't already a good enough
reason for me not to like him the girls
just swooned over him and of course he
acts like he doesn't care
well me and my friend Gio got tired of
being effortlessly shown up by this
pretty boy so we've been practicing in
his driveway just about every free day
we get we may not know any of his fancy
little tricks but I think we're
physically on a level to compete to add
motivation there's a girl I like named
Kelsey in our gym class so I couldn't
afford to be embarrassed by Callum if I
go all out on our first day of floor
hockey we were broken up into eight
teams I led my team to three undefeated
matches before it was time to face
Kalam's team who was also undefeated at
the time my heart was erasing as I
walked up to the line though I didn't
let on to it kallen just had a bored
disinterested look on his face good
maybe I'd take him by surprise
hey I tried to sweep the puck away from
the faceoff but Callum was too quick
I took a defensive position he coolly
brought the puck up to challenge me
leaving it out in front of him for me to
try to snatch it away I didn't take the
bait so he scooped the puck off the
floor of the Fieldhouse seeing my chance
I knocked his stick away and seized the
puck I was already taking off in the
other direction I easily dekes around
the rest of his team and deposited a
shot in my back of the net 1:0 I won the
next faceoff I loved the puck into an
empty corner and chased it down with one
man to beat
I deflected a shot off him into the goal
2-0 Callum and I got back to the centre
circle
he had that same board look on his face
I could tell if I won he was gonna try
to play it off like he was never trying
but he and I and Kelsey for that matter
knew he had gone undefeated in the other
matches plus I had one more trick up my
sleeve to really put him in his place I
won the faceoff again and this time I
went straight for Tallinn and challenged
him directly suddenly he looked
surprised
without looking down I sent the puck
between his legs and dashed around the
side of him as the puck got by him and
safely into my possession I couldn't
help but crack a little bit of a smile
with nothing but an open path to the
goal that's when I felt something hooked
my legs and I went crashing down onto my
face as the post little way into the
corner Calem he had reached back with
his stick and intentionally taken me out
going face-first into the ground and
slamming down my knee hurt but I could
take that but hearing Callum's cocky
defiant oops and seen Kelsey unable to
stop her mouth from falling open and
laughter set me over ears burning I got
to my feet forgetting about the puck the
game and where I was I socked Calum
straight in the joke before he could
retaliate our gym teacher that he yanked
me away from the game and his face was
red as he screamed in my face I didn't
hear any of it my mind was still racing
with anger I found myself sitting
outside the athletic office before I'd
started to calm down Calum was sitting
on the far side of the room I should
have been happy that he was getting
punished too but he had this dumb smirk
on his face somehow I knew my parents
were gonna be a lot more upset than his
when this was all said and done we sat
in silence for a few minutes and an
announcement came over the intercom
please pardon the interruption
attention all students with that please
initiate internal lockdown procedure at
this time now norm
I wouldn't have cared to participate in
lockdown drill but there was something
about this maybe that little hint of
tremble in the principal's voice I think
Callum felt it too felt that it could be
real what should we do I asked him
breaking the silence I don't know it
didn't seem like he was gonna cooperate
but then he added should we go look for
mr. Dyk mr. Dyk was our gym teacher a
huge hulking massive muscle and probably
the safest person in the school to be
around at a time like this
I told Callum okay and we headed back
into the halls by the locker room all of
the lights had been shut off so the only
source of light was coming from the door
at our end of the hall all the way on
the opposite end there's a closet the
door was open and someone was standing
inside facing the inside of the closet
Callum looked like he was about to call
out but I threw my hand up as if to say
hold on he froze and eyed me I wanted to
make sure that we weren't about to
willingly give ourselves up to the
intruder we quietly walked in to get a
better look and see if we knew whoever
was standing there as my eyes adjusted
to the dark and as we got a little bit
closer the person started to take shape
the figure had wide shoulders big ears
and short hair
it was mr. Dyk our teacher only he was
just staring into a dark closet
shoulders shaking no trembling something
was off mr. Dyk I called out we didn't
know what to do
where should we but I trailed off when I
realized that he was not listening he
was just like petrified at the opening
of the equipment closet his whole body
was trembling he was breathing loudly
and and he was whimpering mr. Dyk are
you okay no response he didn't even
acknowledge us what the hell come on we
need to go find another teacher
we've ran around the corner into the
hall that leads into the Fieldhouse one
of the double doors leading into the gym
was cracked open just slightly and I
could see that the lights were off in
there as well other than this faint
orange glow watch out there was some
shattered glass in the floor I looked up
to find someone had broken the glass
cases next to the fire alarm and removed
the fire extinguisher and ax yeah it's
an old school my heart dropped into my
stomach
this meant either one of two things one
that the threat was nearby and recently
broken and retrieved the axe or two that
someone was scared enough to retrieve
the axe for self-defense
neither boated well for Callum and I we
went into the Fieldhouse the door swung
shut behind us shoot he turned back and
tried to open the door we had just come
through but it was locked the orange
colored glow I had seen was coming from
the scoreboard there was a timer on it
counting down with one minute in 33
seconds remaining there was also a score
it was zero zero but in place of the
team names reading Home & Away the team
names read Aris verse kids we walked
into the middle of the field house and
surveyed all around the whole gym was
completely empty as far as I could tell
there was one thought that sat in the
back of my mind though there's this
little room at the top of the bleachers
it's where the scoreboard control room
is from looking at the window I could
tell the lights were off but still the
scoreboard was on naturally we wanted to
get out of there there are several exits
on each side of the Fieldhouse but each
one was locked that left us nothing to
do but sit and wait for the scoreboard
timer to run out buzzer blasted out her
eardrums as an insane like I can't even
describe the horror Crazy Clown crashed
up against the scoreboard room window
with a fire
for us this clown had a wild side unlike
anything I had ever seen the sound of
that buzzer may have hit me hard but the
feeling of despair when it laid eyes on
that clown that monstrous sight hit me
ten times harder a crackle came over the
announcer speakers and circus music no I
am NOT making this up
distorted broken sounding circus music
started playing
ah scoreboard went off again it now read
Eris one kids zero with no time
remaining the door of the scoreboard
room raucously flew open in the cloud
now holding an axe marched it's a big
shoes into the doorway the most devilish
strength on its face the clown bounded
down the bleachers towards us laughing
hysterically as he did so I glanced over
at Kalin wondering if we were going with
fight or flight to my surprise he had
already taken off and left me in the
dust
I turned to book it but for the second
time that day I felt my center of
balance disrupt as a sideways hockey
puck rolls me off my feet and I slammed
into the ground yet again at this point
my knee was throbbing I tried to get
back up as quickly as I could but the
pain was too much and the clown was
already hovering over me
it's a grin stretching unnaturally from
ear to ear as it swung its axe high in
the air in those final moments I found
myself thinking of some of my best and
worst memories my birthday party at age
seven getting in trouble for sneaking
alcohol with my friends opening my
Nintendo DS on Christmas morning and
more
it wasn't like my life was flashing
before my eyes like people talked about
it was more of a scramble to find a
final memory to hold on to that's how I
like to think about it I closed my eyes
[Music]
eyes shot back open to see what had
caused that horrible screech the clown
had somehow been knocked back by
something I looked up it was Callum he
was holding a hockey stick with the
blade turned away using the butt end
like a spear he jabbed at the clowns
face knocking it back i ginger Lee rose
to my feet Talan motion to the floor
where he had already dropped his second
hockey stick these sticks had pretty
flimsy plastic blades but using the
opposite end like Callum we'd be able to
pack a little bit of a punch the clown
recomposed itself and approached us
again it dragged the axe behind leaving
an opening for us to try to make a quick
attack but I knew better than to try to
make a risky first move we waited until
it was close enough and let it take a
wild unbalanced hand I felt my knees
falling up as I jumped back out of the
way but I was able to dodge the attack I
went in first and took a low slash at
the waist and then Callum got in close
dangerously close what was he doing he
reared back with one stabbing motion
obliged his stick into the clown's eyes
socket
[Music]
my jaw dropped as Callum kept hold of
the other end of the hockey stick while
the clown crashed down on its back and
writhed for a moment before going limp
Callum yanked the stick out of the
clown's head blood is squirted
everywhere the clown's eye which
miraculously wasn't crushed was ripped
from its socket and bounced onto the gym
floor still connected to the clown's
head by a nerve like a ball and chain I
honestly didn't know what to say at this
point my knee was throbbing and I felt
like I was gonna throw up
I limped over to the first row of
bleachers and sat down Callum just
squatted on the floor we sat quietly
catching our breath and waited for
someone to find us it was maybe 10
minutes before the school police officer
came in to clear the room
we gave the entire story he insisted
that we visit the nurse which I welcomed
to openly Callum probably didn't need to
be checked out but he went along anyway
figuring it was better than going back
to the office though our little gym
class fight didn't seem like such a big
deal now the school nurse doesn't have a
ton of tools at her disposal
I was given an ice pack for my knee and
told to relax until the cops showed up
while we waited I apologize to Callum
for sacking him in the face earlier and
he told me he felt bad about his
egregious penalty as well he said maybe
he'd join us for a little driveway
hockey sometime and he'd even let me
have a penalty shot whenever he does I
told him that was fair but before he
could respond another announcement came
over the intercom only it wasn't the
all-clear that I had expected that you
were to remain in internal lockdown at
this time please ensure all rooms are
clear the end of the announcement
brought that uncomfortable silence I had
become all too familiar with back into
the room the nurse went over and locked
the door what was going on was there a
second intruder in the school normally
during a lockdown we'd have to get
against the wall and hide on the ground
away from the windows however there were
no windows in the nurse's office so we
just stayed where we were and remained
silent
[Music]
there were footsteps approaching down
the hall I heard echoed streams coming
from another classroom at least this
time we were behind a locked door the
steps continued to approach until they
stopped in front of our door I held my
breath the person outside give a hard
tug on her doorknob it seems like
forever but realistically it was a few
more seconds until the footsteps
continued down the hall onto the next
room I let out a sigh of relief about 30
minutes later we would find out the
reason for that second announcement from
the police chief
who came to visit us at the nurse's
office after the school police officer
sent us on our way he investigated the
clown who appeared to be dead he then
got word that the SWAT team had arrived
and went back to go touch base with them
when they returned to the Fieldhouse and
turned on the lights the body of the
clown was no longer there at that point
they made the second announcement making
sure students and teachers did not think
that it was safe to come out of the
lockdown procedures they had to wreak
leer every single room then after a
meeting with the administration staff
they finally decided that they'd done
everything they could do and finally
gave the all-clear and there had been a
couple of other clown attacks at schools
over the last couple years so Callum and
I were questioned heavily about the
incident however as you can imagine
there were moments that caused them to
roll their eyes they clearly didn't
believe some of them were outlandish
details I'm afraid that may have caused
the validity of our accounts to be
thrown into question but everything in
this story is the truth and I've got
Calum to back me up on that but I let
them know not to just take our word for
it you'll find those hockey sticks that
would use defend off the clown I told
them of course they had already taken
those in for evidence there was just one
problem sometime over the next couple
weeks they ran tests on the DNA left
behind on the sticks which matched the
DNA of someone who had been in a
high-security prison since 2016 and was
still there today obviously I didn't
know how this was possible and they were
coming at me like I had planted this
guy's DNA they're like this whole ordeal
was some stupid prank we had pulled I
couldn't believe the way that they were
talking to me
so that was pretty much the end of that
but unfortunately it wasn't the end of
this nightmare there is one kind of cool
thing about being the victim of a
lockdown attack it got me a lot of
attention at school for the next two
weeks everyone wanted to hear my story
so let's just say I got pretty good at
retelling my dramatic account for any of
the cute girls who asked me about it
unfortunately I was never able to score
that date with Kelsey from gym class but
I had no shortage of female attention
one night I was walking home this girl I
think her name was Ashley
we were walking because I didn't have my
license yet we walked by this alley and
out of the corner of my eye I see
someone standing there staring down the
alley
now this next part happened pretty fast
and I'm still a little bit unsure about
it I turned my head and just before we
walked past the alley I catch a brief
glimpse of the clown the clown from that
day just standing in the alley one eye
staring at me the other eye
just hanging down out of its socket my
heart flipped this can't be happening it
was over Ashley or whatever her name was
stop walking and asked me if I was okay
I looked back and it was just an empty
alley nowhere to even hide what was
going on was my mind playing tricks on
me
is this what PTSD is like I asked her if
she saw anything and she said no but she
was standing on the other side of me she
couldn't have not wanting to look like a
[ __ ] in front of my date I acted as if
I had shrugged it off and changed the
subject but for the rest of that night I
couldn't get the sound of that clowns
laughter out of my head
in fact I really can't say with
certainty that I ever will
[Music]
thanks for listening to all daint a
creepypasta your total for this video
comes out to one dollar and 33 cents but
if you like this video right now I'll
waive that fee and give you everything
you just listen to absolutely free guest
narrators today include after dark
analysis and the music was scored by OST
maker today's video is brought to you by
the sea ZZZ world merch store where you
can pick up the new my life is a horror
movie merch check out these videos for
other creepy clown school lockdown
incidents and remember to subscribe to
see ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]